since her humble beginnings of vlogging
about dropping out of high school Emma
Chamberlain has since gone on to amass a
whopping 12 million YouTube subscribers
start her own coffee company launch a
podcast Grace the cover of Vogue
collaborate with luxury Brands like
Louis Vuitton and karchay and even host
coveted Red Carpet Events like the Met
Gala there's no question that Emma
Chamberlain is one of the most beloved
it girls and everyone's parasocial
bestie so today I'm going to live my
best Emma Chamberlain Inspired Life and
follow everything that she eats in a day
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
I'll be eating like YouTuber turned gen
Z it girl Emma Chamberlain but of course
not quite because my needs are unique so
I'm gonna be using her alleged meals as
a template for teaching gentle nutrition
and inspiring what I make that works for
my body and me also a reminder that this
diet was compiled from some primary and
secondary sources so I really can't
speak to its legitimacy or accuracy
right now also a reminder that this is
just what I ate on a random day and it's
not meant to be copied or recommended as
how you should eat so always speak to a
registered dietitian about your unique
needs let me hop in here to chat about
today's sponsor fetch so these past few
years have been financially challenging
for a lot of us I mean have you guys
seen the cost of lettuce it is out of
control so I'm all for finding little
ways to save wherever I can so fetch is
a super easy to use free app that lets
you instantly earn rewards on anything
you buy like Le literally anything
Amazon purchases restaurants retail
stores you name it you're not limited to
a certain list of random participating
stores that you never shop at so
basically after you buy anything you
just snap your receipt or e-recee on
your phone which literally takes seconds
to do and then you earn points for
everything that you buy and those points
can be saved and then redeemed for
things that you actually want it's not
like you get a free sample of toothpaste
or a food that you will never eat you
can get gift cards from places that you
shop often like Starbucks Amazon Walmart
or VISA it's obviously really nice to
get good free stuff that you need for
just buying whatever you're already
gonna buy so if you want to try out
fetch for yourself check out my link in
the description and use my code Abby
fetch to get 5 000 points when you snap
your first receipt Abby get that coffee
brewing okay so Emma is well known for
her love of coffee which obviously you
guys know I'm aligned with so I'll
usually make a latte and I take two
shots of espresso put some vanilla
almond milk in it and then I put vanilla
nut pod creamer in it considering Emma
owns her own coffee company I knew her
coffee order would not disappoint so I
have remade her vanilla a milk latte
here and I know she adds a little almond
creamer we don't have a ton of options
in Canada for non-dairy creamers but
this is what we got it is super sweet so
I'm just gonna like add a tinch
tinch tinch is the official measurement
let's see
foreign it's good so Emma has her coffee
first thing in the morning on an empty
stomach which in Wellness culture World
online is like a big No-No Abby can you
walk us through this you got it girl so
we hear from a lot of Wellness
influencers that drinking coffee first
thing in the morning on an empty stomach
will increase your cortisol levels AKA
your stress hormone which is already
naturally highest in the morning and
while there is some truth to this we
also know that any effect that caffeine
appears to have on cortisol levels
diminishes with regular intake in other
words if you have already built a habit
of drinking coffee first thing in the
morning your body will adapt and not
interpret your double double as like a
life or death fight or flight situation
as for drinking coffee on an empty
stomach we don't have any evidence this
will exacerbate this result though
theoretically it may help to have like a
food buffer on board the bigger issue is
that because coffee is a stimulant it
can cause digestive distress in
sensitive folks and again pairing it
with something may help to reduce this
effect and for others some creamer or
milk is more than enough everyone's
tolerance and reactions will differ all
right I'm glad we sorted that out let's
take a look at what we are having for
breakfast breakfast almost every single
day is two fried eggs two over hard eggs
salt on it pepper on it everything but
the bagel seasoning on it and then I put
some Cholula on that and then I cut up a
whole avocado put that on top and then I
eat it and that's my breakfast every day
so Emma's go-to avocado toast has
already made its rounds here on my
channel I actually taste tested it when
I made a bunch of YouTubers different
kind of like iconic go-to breakfast and
it was really good so I'm not
disappointed who we're making it again
Plus let's be real avocado toast with
some fried eggs on top are like a tried
and true hunger crushing combo I don't
really care if this breakfast seems like
very 2018. I am here for it let's get
cooking a little bit of olive oil a
little bit of butter for flavor eggs
just like
scream for better in my opinion this one
is like significantly bigger than this
one
okay maybe not significantly but I'm
always going to go big or go home
yes I always feel like when we film this
birdie I just get nervous and then
I break the Yoke so
she good
this is so awkward to crack on I don't
know what I'm doing I overthink these
things when the camera comes out and I
like forget how to cook
foreign
possibly but who's going to notice when
we've got some spices on top nobody's
gonna know nobody's gonna know nobody's
gonna know nobody's gonna know they're
gonna know
how would they know a little fresh
Cracked Pepper
we're gonna do the fancy salt today
cause why not if I'm making breakfast on
a weekday I'm gonna bust out some fancy
salt
[Applause]
smells good okay gotta feel
the goods I feel like the right one's it
I can feel it avocado power just pulsing
through
my veins don't let me down
oh
she's green
but what the [__] kind of avocado is
that oh that is Disappointment a big ass
pit the pit Works in
serious ways all right so it's going to
be one and a half avocados in this
recipe oh and this one oh no nope not
that one
all right let's try this again because
this feels good
nice
small But Mighty okay let's get the
toast down all right
scrape up this disappointing example of
a [__] avocado
you
see like it's gonna need a lot
you know what I doubted this avocado I
doubted it but she covered her bases
first things first salt second thing
second everything but the bagel
seasoning
third things third is our girl Emma
loves Cholula so I'll do a little
Cholula but I want to show you my little
twisty twist here because this is how I
really have discovered that I love
avocado toast
little Cholula don't worry I'm going to
add more heat in just a hot minute and
everything but the bagel with Mike's hot
honey
oh my goodness folks
it's gonna blow your mind
okay
that
hey guys
aren't you proud for Christmas this year
I got
a plastic flipper so now no one has to
harass me in the comments every single
time I use a metal spatula on non-stick
which I know is offensive so I do
apologize for it
this is how I like it this is how I like
an egg perfect ooey gooey yolk Crispy
Crunchy edges fried in butter and I need
a little fruit action in here so we'll
throw down a few berries
just around everything out
mango
I'm excited
I just readjust a few things folks
we give her a poke
come here
um
it is so good
and super duper well balanced we got
fiber rich carbs in our sourdough and
our fruit lots of healthy fats in the
avocado plus the egg and of course some
really great high quality protein in
that egg as well hello
hmm
so our girl Emma is an avid Runner and
she'll often now Vlog about her running
routine and training for a marathon now
thankfully the double shot of espresso
is giving me cardio energy but yeah girl
has had two kids so I'm gonna do what my
pelvic floor will allow me to do wish me
luck
[Music]
if peeling your pants is cool consider
me Miles Davis oh
all right got some good movement in now
it's time for lunch so back when I
reviewed Emma's harpist Bazaar video she
basically said that she was just not
much of a cook and usually she would
just like Postmates in some lunch but if
you are watching her Channel or
following her on social media you now
know that she has taken up cooking and
she's been experimenting in the kitchen
trying to have fun with it to the point
that is now something that she actually
really enjoys doing Alicia makes it seem
like that but yeah she has a bunch of
videos on her Channel where she's trying
out new delicious looking recipes so I
thought we'd put one to the test and
make some tempeh fresh rolls let's get
some ingredients okay I love a good rice
paper wrap because I feel like it is
just a vessel for so many delicious
ingredients and it's giving me a good
reason to use up any little bits and
pieces that I found in my fridge so we
have some cabbage slaw some sweet peas
bell pepper carrots avocado I've got
these Millet and brown rice Ramen and
some tempeh as well as some sesame seeds
so we're going to
get this in the bath
give it a good rub down until it's just
pliable but not too sticky like a
delicate balance
spread this out onto my
cutting board
I'm going to add some noodles
some tempeh
veggies
and some sesame seeds all right this is
not my forte but we're going to give it
a go
in
oh I should have probably not ever
don't judge me
oh God I'm out of practice
all right well the next one will be
better well I work to remedy this
situation Abby can we go over the tempeh
thing on it so we know that Emma is a
vegetarian which explains why she leans
towards more vegetarian proteins like
eggs tofu beans and tempeh now tempeh
tends to be a bit of an underrated plant
protein but it actually packs quite the
nutritious punch in fact three ounces of
tempeh contains 60 percent more protein
than the same amount of tofu it also
contains Calcium and iron which are
essential nutrients for a vegan or
vegetarian diet on top of that since
tempeh is a fermented soybean product it
is also rich in probiotics making it
beneficial for Digestive Health tempeh
is also considered a complete protein
meaning that it contains all essential
amino acids but while we're here it's
worth mentioning that the common
misconception about plant-based diets is
that they don't provide enough protein
or are missing essential amino acids
however there's actually very little
evidence of protein deficiency in vegans
and vegetarians as long as they a are
eating enough calories and B eat enough
food variety and while a lot of
plant-based protein sources are missing
or are low in one or more essential
amino acids when you get a variety of
protein sources it does fill in those
gaps so for example peanut butter is low
in methionine and bread is low in lysine
so think of it like having a piece of
paper with a hole in it and then another
piece with the hole in a completely
different place when you layer them on
top you've effectively filled in those
gaps so yeah eat the rainbow and you'll
be good Abby back at you you can't have
fresh rolls without a little dip so
we're gonna do some
peanut sauce
and I'm totally going to Freestyle this
big lug of peanut butter a little splash
of rice wine vinegar
little soy
Ginger
just a titch
garlic
I'm gonna add hot honey which kind of
doubles from the sweetness and the spice
and we need something like milk
experience I only have a Noah one second
just a little almond milk to thin it out
let's hope this will blend let's see
what happens when I blend them
usually when I freestyle a recipe like
this in a small portion what ends up
happening is I try it so many times
until it's just non-existent so
and I like lime
this will make it better
[Music]
much better okay so I need to work on my
rolling technique but I think they look
pretty good so we've got protein in the
tempeh healthy fats in the nut butter
and the avocado carbs in our noodles and
lots of fiber rich veg this one's nice
and tight yeah yeah
just the tip
mmm that's so good the peanut sauce
is cake
all right so it's around 3 P.M and I
feel like your girl could use a snack so
let's take a look at some options I'm a
big snacker my favorite snack for the
past year has been these flax crackers
they're called Mary's Gone Crackers
they're like black seed other seed who
knows what's in it a bunch of seeds in a
cracker and they taste so good and I eat
those with spicy hummus um another snack
is I make little mini cauliflower pizzas
because I found these little cauliflower
Thins and I just put a little bit of
marinara sauce on a little bit of pesto
a little bit of vegan mozzarella um
sometimes I'll chop up a little veggie
Italian sausage put that on there maybe
some green olives bake that for a little
bit put some nutritional yeast on that
take a jar of peanut butter or take a
jar of almond butter like any jar of nut
butter I can find and I'll just take a
spoonful of it and eat that amazing love
the variety and I like that we have a
good range between like super quick easy
convenient snacks and a little bit more
kind of meal prepped snacks and while I
also love me some Mary's Gone Crackers
and hummus I feel like we're on an Emma
recipe kick so I'm going to take a stab
at her kind of like cauliflower pizza
situation I'm gonna go find my neuch and
get things going me again so you may
have noticed that nutritional yeast is a
very popular staple amongst plant-based
dieters and for good reason it can be
difficult to get enough vitamin B12 on a
vegan diet since most sources come from
animal products however just two
teaspoons of fortified nutritional yeast
provide more than 300 percent of the
daily recommendation for a vitamin B12
not to mention it's also a complete
protein meaning contains all nine
essential amino acids and let's be real
regardless of the nutritional benefits
the stuff tastes so good especially if
you love like a Cheesy nutty flavor okay
so Emma uses like a cauliflower kind of
pizza crust situation which I'm not
usually super jazzed about but we're
going and give it a try so my little tip
when I'm making pizza and I don't have
access to like a pizza oven obviously is
I preheat My Pan in the oven just for a
few minutes while it's warming up it
definitely helps to get the bottom nice
and crispy we're gonna do
hmm
a little marinara
then I've got a little sundry tomato
pesto I'm just going to add a lot of
really yummy
flavor plus some healthy fats I'm gonna
slice up some Kalamata olives
lots of mozzarella cheese
and
our niche
this is going into a 450 degree oven
until the cheese melts and that crust
gets golden brown if cauliflower crust
Browns
I don't know we're gonna see one
eternity later this legit looks
delicious this could be a little snack
or could totally be a base for a really
delicious meal and the crust actually
held up pretty nicely and I think it's
because of my little hack
look at that
we've got fiber in the crust we got
healthy fats in our olives plus some
protein in our news
that's surprisingly really good
it is officially dinner time and your
girl is hungry Emma give me something
good but
wanting to make since I started my new
cooking Journey about a week ago I'll
show you a photo they're called Buddha
Bowls but I actually like tofu although
it gives me terrible gas it looks
pretty impressive I love a good nourish
Bowl I think it's just a really easy way
to use up any leftover bits and pieces
that we have in the fridge which has
kind of been the theme of today because
we kind of did that for lunch with the
rice paper rolls as well but I thought
it was interesting that Emma mentioned
experiencing a lot of gas and bloating
from tofu Abby can you elaborate on this
for us so tofu is made from soybeans
which contain oligosaccharides which are
a FODMAP however even though tofu is
technically a low FODMAP food tolerance
is highly individualized and will also
depend on the amount and type of tofu
consumed so for example silken tofu
tends to be higher in oligosaccharides
compared to extra firm tofu we also know
that pressing the moisture from the tofu
can also be an effective way to lower
the amount of oligosaccharides it
contains so it's possible that she can
tolerate some firm tofu and some tempeh
which is actually lower in
oligosaccharides because of the
fermentation process all that said if
you're vegan or vegetarian and your
protein sources are limited and you want
to continue to eat tofu or other soy
based products without experiencing gas
then you can always opt for taking a
supplement like Bingo before a meal
which is a digestive enzyme that
specifically helps to digest foods
containing those oligosaccharides okay I
am super excited about this I popped
some broccoli cauliflower sweet potatoes
and tofu onto the same baking sheet with
a little bit of olive oil and some
nutritional yeast salt and pepper super
simple we gotta keep it easy I'm going
to do a little bit of lemon juice here
onto some kale and some olive oil
and we need some salt
all right a little bit of a rub down
here you gotta massage kale you gotta
give it some love to break down some of
those really tough fibers because if you
have IBS or just like a really sensitive
tummy as I do kale can be a little rough
on the old bowels if you know what I
mean so this takes 30 seconds out of
your day and it'll save you at least 30
minutes of Agony done all right let's
get our veg all right
no idea why you're saying that so I feel
like most of these nourish Bowls have
quinoa as the base but spoil alert I
hate quinoa so I much prefer sweet
potato
we've got
all the goods
get in here that's a really nice base
[Applause]
and I like the sweetness from a sweet
potato as well
next we're going to do a little dressing
here a little sauce action okay we got
some tahini
[Music]
lemon
a little maple
and just to thin it out a little bit
my water gotta stay hydrated
all right I've got
this last little half of avocado might
as well use her up because you know it's
not going to last till tomorrow
here some sesame seeds
this is a nourish Bowl I can get behind
we've got lots of protein in our tofu
healthy fats in the tahini and the
sesame seeds and avocado lots of fiber
in our veg plus some carb action in the
sweet potatoes and honestly it looks
delicious
hmm
the sauce
yes please all right the day would not
be complete without my beloved bedtime
snack and I know that our girl Emma
loves her fruit so let's take a look
what some of her options are or plums
like when plums are in season I can just
shove down like 10 of those
you guys
okay so plums are well out of season so
out of season berries are gonna have to
do and I don't think we've had anything
sweet today so I'm gonna upgrade these
with a little chocolate as I did on my
Tick Tock a little while back so let me
show what I'm gonna do I've melted some
chocolate chips here
hello I mean
this is all we really need right
gonna throw in some bloops
trust me
two two
some hemp hearts
sliced almonds
and let's give her a stir
and I just put these into like little
clumps
okay
we're gonna pop this into a fridge or
freezer just to set up for a few minutes
and then we'll have our snack okay so I
fully acknowledge that these look like
turds but they taste delicious I'm just
adding a little sprinkle of flour to
sell because I feel like that's gonna
just take it up
a notch trust me these are so delicious
plus they've got fiber in our berries
less healthy fats protein and fiber in
the hemp hearts and nuts
hmm
juicy and crunchy
and I think that's a wrap on eating like
our girl Emma and I gotta say it feels
like a pretty good day I got lots of new
plant-based recipe inspiration got a lot
of different variety in the day and I
got to have my chocolate so if Emma
decides she wants to Zone in on the food
content I am here for it and on that
note that is all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on Whose diet you'd like
to see me attempt next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye foreign
[Music]